you
Welcome everyone who has joined us this evening. It is Monday, June 1st, 2026,
3 o'clock and this joint meeting of the Huntsville City Council and Huntsville
Board of Education is called to order. We welcome everyone who is joining us here
in the table, in the chambers, or who may be joining us virtually. It has taken a
little bit of scheduling to pull this together, but we are very grateful for
everyone who has joined us tonight. The City of Huntsville is honored to host
this meeting. It's been a number of years since we have had a joint session and we
welcome those who have joined the Board of Education, those who have joined us, my
fellow council members, Mayor Battle, the superintendent, Dr. Sutton. We have had a
great partnership historically. We have an opportunity to explore that
partnership further tonight and look forward to learning about how our city
is growing, how we are adjusting to that growth, and how we can fund future growth.
So before we go any further, Board President Carlos Matthews, thank you
again for your work in helping bring this, make this meeting possible. I'll
turn some time over to you for comments. I appreciate that. I want to thank
everybody for being here this afternoon. It has been since 2021 since the last
time we've had a joint session between the Board of Education and the City
Council. It is a tough task to try to get all the schedules together to try to
make this happen, but we really wanted to show that these two bodies work
together for the citizens of Huntsville to make sure they have the best
education and the best living environments that they could possibly
have with their tax dollars. So today we hope to have some fruitful
conversations and get some really good information on how our city is growing
and what our school system is doing going forward. So I'll turn it back over to you.
Thank you, Mr. Matthews. So the agenda today has been created with feedback from
council members, from board members, and from the public. Mayor Battle is fond of
saying that we want to not just be the biggest city, we want to be the best city.
And that requires attention to growth and again the partnerships that we've had. So
our agenda tonight is going to focus on how we are growing and that presentation
on demographics and population overview will be given by James Vandiver, our city
demographer, and he will be joined by Dennis Madsen who's here to answer
questions as well. We'll have discussion following that. Then we will have a
presentation on the Huntsville City Schools capital plan expansion. Dr. Sutton
has agreed to give that overview for us. Again, any discussion after that? And
finally, now that we know how we're growing, how we're accommodating that
growth through the capital plan, we'll talk about how we're funding that growth.
And that will be presented by our director of urban and economic development,
Shane Davis. And again, conversations about that and then we will summarize. So
anybody have questions about the agenda? Any comments on that? All right, we're
going to go forward then and we will begin with a presentation from James
Vandiver on demographics and population overview. Thank You Councilwoman. Good
afternoon everyone. Good afternoon. All right, so today I'm going to talk a
little bit about the development review, go over some data from last year from
2025 and give you some indications of what's going to happen this year and
and beyond. So last year we had a really good year with development with
development in the city, with residential development. In fact, in terms of how new
housing added, we had the second highest on record. I think 2024 was the
only other, was the record-breaking year. So we've had a really strong couple of
years in terms of residential development. It's been kind of an anomaly
really and we are starting to come down from that and a lot of that had to do
with a historic boom in multifamily housing. Something we haven't seen
in the 40 years that we've done the development review and so we're starting
to see that with the building permit numbers that we saw last year, the
housing starts. We saw a 24% decrease compared to 2024 but then you start, when
you break down the numbers, you can kind of see where the trends are going and
we see that our single-family detached housing starts are starting to go back
up. We had a 2% increase last year even with that, the overall decrease and the
overall decrease was mostly because of that multifamily. We're still building
more multifamily. We in fact will probably have about eight new
developments open up this year. So the spigot hasn't completely been turned off
but at the same time we're going back to historical norms. Before 2020 our
average was between a thousand and fifteen hundred new homes a year. So
that's, we're going back towards that after an anomalous couple of years.
Typically, I know many of you have seen my development review presentation. A lot
of times I talk about city-wide data and or sometimes I do district-specific
presentations but this time I wanted to do something a little more useful to the
joint members of the City Council and School Board. We wanted to look at the
development review by elementary school zones. So the maps on the left, the green
maps are building permits or housing starts. The maps on the right for the
next few slides are certificates of occupancy. Those are homes that are ready
to be occupied. So I'll start out on the left. This is, these are these are total
numbers for single-family plus multifamily and then I'll go in and
break them down here in just a minute. The single, sorry, so the combined building
permits, the top five school zones for building permits last year were
Providence with just over 500 units followed by Williams, Rolling Hills, MLK,
and Hampton Cove. And then on the other side we have the certificates of occupancy,
the homes that have that are ready for to be lived in. Providence had more than
1,200 housing units added followed by Blossomwood which had just under a
thousand. A lot of that has to do with Blossomwood including downtown. Downtown
had several new apartment complexes go in there as well as the trailhead
development on the other side of Chapman Mountain. Morris has Mid City so that's
why you have a large number of new units in that school zone. Williams of course
has your fast growing areas in Limestone County as well as around the Zert Road
area. And then Chaffee in South Huntsville has Hayes Farm and a lot of
the homes in that zone were centered around that development. So we'll break
it down and look at single-family residential data first. So looking at the
single-family on the left building permits, Providence, I'm gonna sound like
a broken record, Providence had the most building permits and COs of every
category no matter how you look at it. And so Providence was the top followed
by Hampton Cove and Goldsmiths-Shiffman. We're still seeing some housing growth
there but it's not growing as much as it had been in previous years. But we're
still seeing that as a strong growth area. Followed by Williams and
we'll start seeing that number creep up over the next few years with the
development going on in Limestone County and then Blossomwood rounded out the top
five for building permits. On the CO side, Providence again just over 300 units
followed by Goldsmiths-Shiffman and Hampton Cove and Blossomwood and Williams. So
really it's those five schools that they just mixed it up a little bit on either
either way you look at it. So those are your five schools, school zones that are
seeing the most single-family development in the city. So we'll take a
look at multifamily units. All right so as we mentioned earlier we started to
see a bit of a decrease in multifamily units starting construction. But we're
still seeing a lot of new multifamily units come online just because they
started construction several years prior. In Providence, Providence, Rolling Hills
Williams and MLK were the four zones that we saw substantial multifamily
development. Beyond that you didn't really see a whole lot beyond a couple
of duplexes around town. And then on the certificates of occupancy side though
with multifamily like I said some of the apartment complexes that started
construction a few years prior are now coming online. Providence and Blossomwood
both had over 900 new housing units followed by Morris with Mid-City,
Williams and Chaffee. So I'm gonna give you guys some key takeaways to wrap this
up and it's a bit of an outlook just based on what we've been seeing so far.
We're already in June of this year so we've started to see a few trends in in
2026. So one of the big things is that we're going to see building permits go
up this year. We've had we had a really good year last year with subdivision lot
approvals. The Huntsville Planning Commission approved more single-family
subdivision lots in 2025 than they had since 2007. So we're doing
better in single-family than we have in 20 years. So that's that's really good
that's a really good indicator that over the next couple years we're gonna see
more single-family housing come online. In fact year-to-date we have had 40%
increase in single-family housing starting single-family housing starts
compared to 2025 up to this point. We will see our COs go down though because
of that lack of multi-family projects and but like I said we're still gonna see a
few of those and as I mentioned earlier we had the average number of units we
got per year was between a thousand and fifteen hundred prior to 2020. We're
still gonna see around 2,000 homes this year so we're still well above the
historical averages and we're doing great. Some near-term growth areas I
wanted to mention here just to kind of point out some areas that we're
watching for growth. Providence of course as you saw it was dominating doesn't
matter if it's starting a home or finishing home. Providence seemed to have
the most most homes being added and started. Limestone of course with the new
school coming I know that's gonna be a hot spot for development. One that we
really need to be watching out for is North Huntsville. It's somewhat flown
under the radar though I know last week there was a City Council considered the
rezoning of a fairly large potentially a large residential development in North
off of the northern bypass or SR 255. Definitely that is definitely an area
that we we see as an area that will have more residential development so
Rolling Hills, MLK those zones will be we'll need to watch out there for
potential enrollment growth in those areas. Hampton Cove will continue to grow
though there are some natural constraints in Hampton Cove that will
eventually restrict the development in that area and then South Huntsville in
the Hayes Farm development that still has some potential for growth in there.
And beyond 2026 I really think those two big hot spots for growth are going to be
West Huntsville. I mean limestone is basically a blank canvas when it comes
to development. Got all the economic development projects going on out there
plus the new school I mean it's it's it's ripe for new development. And then
North Huntsville as well with the northern bypass and with all the
commercial and economic development going on there. Definitely see the
Rolling Hills MLK elementary school zones seeing some growth over the next few
years. So with that I'll take any questions. You guys give me curveballs I
do have Dennis and Shane with me. And there's any problems. Before we open to
questions will those slides be available to will be posted be posting them on a
website sending them out via email. What would be the best way to access those?
We can certainly make them available. Okay we will work that out. Questions for
Mr. Vandiver. I don't really have a question but what I would like to have
is the data that you broke it down there I like for us to have that on a regular
basis as you break that you get that information so that the superintendent
to see if O can use that data to they plan for our future capital plans.
We'll just have it yearly whenever the development plan is released presented
planning Commission that you all get it. Yeah I think that would be good enough
but I'll ask them to see if O and the superintendent with what the cadence
should be if they feel they need it more than that but for now I think that will work.
Okay good. Questions. Mr. Vandiver thank you so much for the presentation. Can you
explain to us so that we can re-explain or to anyone watching how the
multifamilies were included in the numbers you guys gave for our capital
planning processes. We know that that multifamilies it's like a different
math and and we're taking a lot of hits that we didn't capture that and so I
just want to know how your methodology into that. Of course. Yes the
multifamily multifamily works a little bit different especially for schools
because you know single families kind of considered the traditional family home
but in a lot of cases we have been noticing with the data that some
multifamily developments have been having more more families and so we we've
looked at some of the multifamily in terms of you know whether or not it's
multi unit like multi-story apartment complex versus some of the single
family for rent properties that you've seen especially off of South Parkway and
so we've been looking at that and and the school system has been very helpful
with giving us some data on that on in terms of enrollment and trying to figure
out how to model how multifamily works with with the enrollment of the school
system. So the follow-up to that question what is the math for if you have a
certificate of occupancy whether it's single family or multifamily what's the
math that translates into we're predicting X number of children will be
coming to the school. Sure so when we're when we're doing population and
enrollment projections typically our rule of thumb is single family will have
nine out of ninety percent of single family homes are usually occupied whereas
multifamily it's probably closer to 80 percent there's a lot more fluidity when
it comes to multifamily units so that's what we use on that when we come when it
comes to the number of number occupants per unit which is it's pretty important
for the for those projections as well once again single family it tends to
have a higher number probably closer to 2.5 persons per household whereas a
multifamily unit probably has somewhere between 1.5 and 2 it depends on the area
as well like research park we would expect to have a lower persons occupancy
per household just because you have a lot of singles or you know couples that
live in like mid-city research park whereas place like South Huntsville or
Hampton Cove even in a multifamily complex it may be a little bit higher so
yeah that's how we project those and even when you have that number you don't
know if it's going to be elementary middle school high school that's you're
just using a number of saying here's the number of people and we don't know
really what age so it's hard to tell we're constantly getting better with our
projections but yeah we're getting there so yeah other questions I don't have any
specific increase for you mr. Vandebrouik did just want to express a note of
gratitude when you and mr. Madsen sat down with the board two years back when
we were going through the capital planning process your your data and your
evaluation was extremely helpful and I think today reassures myself as
hopefully as well as anybody watching that your data is also not just accurate
but reflected in the capital plan that was approved in terms of a long-range
capital plan we were able to with y'all's help and assistance from the
city and the administration identify those near those near-term growth
corridors as well as the long term and between a new feeder pattern out west
a new expansion facility for the Cove area we were able to address those needs
I just wanted to say thank you for your efforts and mr. Madsen as well as your
team so very much appreciate it thank you thank you oh yeah I can you tell us
a little bit more about your like was any of this a surprise that when you
were going back to review it is this information that you were expecting to
have I mean we've talked over the years and can you explain more about your
methodology I think you know we say these words and sometimes I feel like
it's met with disbelief or people don't understand the process or they don't
trust it so can you give us a little bit more information about the methodology
so we can make sure that we're explaining it properly and that we're
we're doing our due diligence as well absolutely so in a lot of these high
growth areas we have known about them for many years whether it comes whether
it's limestone County whether it's out in the Cove area and North Huntsville as
well that's kind of our emerging growth area up there as well those are not
surprises to us we work with we work on these many years out in advance and we
do enroll we've done we do projections 20 25 years out we look at all the
developed land in a certain area over we have an excellent GIS department that
helps us out with that looking at floodplain sub development it constraints
to development and seeing where we're development might happen and that
absolutely helps us out and so looking at that we figure out where the
development land is going and then we can do residential land calculations
based on you know if we think this area is going to be more single-family versus
multifamily and so that so we have a pretty good number or pretty good
forecast of where the housing units will be in the future or what like an
ultimate build out would be in that kind of scenario councilmember mr. Meredith
how much of a disruption to your projecting our big changes in zoning such
as the one that happened at our last council meeting where I believe it was
over certainly over 200 acres of land that had been c4 are now our twos what
does that do to your ability to forecast well in that specific case if it was a c4
going to an r2 c4 could do multifamily whereas r2 is probably I mean it still
can do some multifamily at least like townhomes but actually probably lower our
numbers a little bit based on the forecast of what that we've done for
that area thank you council members any other questions all right James thank
you very much thank you for your presentation tonight for sharing that
information and also let's make sure to follow up yearly and make sure that this
that kind of data is available to the school system now that we have a picture
of growth let's take a look at capital plan and how we are planning for that
thank you dr. Robertson and thank you city council members mayor battle for
always supporting us as you see tonight mr. Dane who is our CSFO will be
presenting that update on our capital plan I want to thank the board for the
support and the forward thinking we are entering the fourth year of this plan
is going very rapidly with a lot of projects going hopefully we will meet
soon using the data to plan the years after this 10 years because we want to
keep up with the growth of the city so we'll turn over to mr. Dane at this time
but I do want to thank you and your team for always supporting and providing what
we need and this board for their support but it's not a set your day yeah good
afternoon thank you board thank you council for the chance to relay and
update our capital plan for you again this is a capital plan that we started
in 2024 it's approximately 600 million dollars it's actually 600 million dollars
plus I think that's probably important to realize but with that number going up
and down it is dependent on the flexibility that we asked for and that
we do need as we go through the rest of this capital plan again a 10-year
implementation starting with 2024 and the goal of this is obviously to
modernize facilities whether that's for renovations or basic deferred maintenance
catching up deferred maintenance or brand new buildings and the capital plan
does align with our mission to provide a safe and supportive learning environment
characterized by quality staff rigorous academic instruction innovative
programs outstanding extracurricular opportunities and exceptional resources
going back to the beginning of the capital plan we did work a lot with mr.
Vandiver and mr. Madsen and the city with penny and and everybody to get this
version of the capital plan together as you heard previously there is a lot of
forecasting that goes into the makeup of all of our capital plans every
iteration of it but certainly there was a lot that went into this again this
this was ongoing up to the spring of 2024 where we held community meetings
and all of our feeder patterns that would have been affected which is all
over our feeding the patterns we solicited feedback in person and online
met with city organizations such as an issue of the chamber city leaders
retired educators etc and then ultimately brought a very well discussed
and communicated capital plan to the board for approval in May and then the
court the DOJ the court approved our capital plan in September of 2024 the
funding structure for the capital plan is very diversified at this point about
60 to 65 percent of it is going to come from public financing in which case I
will work through the finance office with the city as well as all of their
team in order to and we have worked together to develop a plan to fund like
I said about 63 percent of it and then the remainder of that is funded by
local dollars local dollars being what we send over from our general fund as
well as dollars provided by the state so 60 percent publicly funded 20 ish percent
locally funded 20 ish percent funded by state state dollars for the purpose of
capital expenditures capital plan is a phased execution it does align with
fiscal capacity we can't do everything all up front so we do have to stagger
this out when you start that out you're able to take advantage of contractor
availability schedule availability funding availability because to do this
all up front just as impossible but we are lucky we're fortunate to have you
know a six and a half mils of ad valorem taxes that are collected by the city for
Huntsville City Schools capital growth and that is where the 60 ish percent of
our funding is coming from is from that six and a half mils and then of course
we do work with the city we work with the demographers we work with the growth
side of the city to make sure that we are to monitor the capital plan that we
are tracking the way we think we're going to be tracking as we set out two
years ago to go there is work happening at every school in every feeder pattern
not only are you getting either a new school or a renovation but we are
catching up deferred maintenance that was foregone for a little while which is
extremely important and there is still ongoing maintenance our facilities
teams continue to provide just general planned maintenance and repairs to our
buildings but that's that's now in addition to the deferred maintenance
that we're getting caught up so we're happy that every school and every
district district in our school district is seeing action from the capital plan
we went over the sequencing with the projects already but obviously we're
focused you know when student needs first what kind of revenues do we have
to support capital operational needs operational effects to our to our
repairs and maintenance team facilities teams what are the construction costs
are there are there better times to borrow better times to to get with GC's
to find GC's to have a plenty of a big enough pool to perk to bid on to make
sure that we're getting the best pricing and of course all of those things mean
you have to be you have to be flexible because we are subject to change and
things do change but so far we haven't had any big changes so that that we're
fortunate that way and then individual contracts and and projects are subject
to individual board approval so just because we have a ten-year capital plan
doesn't mean that every plan in that every project in that plan is
automatically board approved we still bring owner architects agreements to the
board for approval we bring projects like we had an hour ago in our in our
college board meeting to the board for approval so every project in the capital
plan does see board approval at several levels as you know we finished our
central office in our HCT our CTE department or building about a year ago
now I think we've been in there almost exactly a year over on the North Parkway
so we're excited about that that's a new central office for us and a new career
tech which is extremely exciting for our school system all of our ten softball
and baseball fields have been completed now we have installed turf on every one
of those in our district and we are efforting to replace the old pod gems
that all of our schools with a new updated version of the gym as you can
see we completed those champion Highlands we still have some in progress
and then some future projects that will start within the next year or so
Columbia High School we have completed our Innovation Center which opened in
2025 if you haven't been by there I suggest you go look at that it's a very
it's very cool place to be if you're a student it's a very modern type facility
does get our students ready to think about innovation technology business
podcast I mean different types of tech stuff and hopefully careers jogs some
ideas for our students at Columbia High School and then in front of Columbia
High School is our JROTC training facility that we've started as you can
see we intend to open that up at the end of this calendar year there's a rendering
of it there to the right pretty cool building at Hampton Cove and Goldsmith
we have added classrooms to both of those I believe four classrooms to one
and five to the other I can never remember which is which but both have
seeded classroom expansion to accommodate growth in that area and then
at Jemison McNair we have the new sixth grade wing being added on to
the McNair side to the left to to welcome our sixth grade students coming
in from the elementary schools in district one so we're very excited about
that part of this sixth grade wing addition there will be a little bit of
an expansion to the McNair cafeteria serving line area to accommodate those
those students with the option to potentially you know revisit that CMP
kitchen area further down the road as enrollment grows super excited for that
to open in August of 2026 a few months ago we bid Chapman Chapman and STEM
Magnet Middle School as well as the Montview STEM Magnet Elementary School
both of those are going well I believe our walls are starting to go up in both
schools yeah so we're making some good headway there excited for Montview to
open August of next year that's full middle school we just got board approval
to to start that construction here a little while ago excited for that to
start in August of 2028 our new Limestone County school will be a P8 out in East
Limestone County which is West Huntsville slated to open August 2028 and
of course we've recently worked with the city to acquire property in Hampton Cove
for a future site we don't exactly know what that's going to be yet but it's
likely you know an elementary or middle school depending on you know what the
continued work with the city produces for us to contemplate over the next
several years but something to open you know around August 2033 and that's all I
have for the presentation if you have any questions discussion council members
mr. Merritt when can we expect to do the groundbreaking for the Limestone County
school we're hoping this fall don't know exactly which month yet but we need to
probably get going on that ASAP so I would say I think somewhere around
September October timeframe is where our schedule shows us right okay and
generally speaking who wins the contracts on school building the low bid
no I mean who is getting low but what company is currently engaged in building
schools yeah yes so we do you have an idea of which contractors will be
available to bid on that I mean we really don't know in that yeah it's
gonna be the typical names Lee fight Pierce others I don't know that yet I
mean that answers my question I think between the city and us we're keeping
our local builders pretty busy so we do have to keep away keep abreast of that
where I was trying to figure out is which one of it was going to be a local
I know the low bidder gets it regardless but historically has it been local folks
that we have ongoing relationships with versus someone that comes in that we
maybe only built one or two schools or did one or two renovations yes or
historically it is local for the most part local contractors thank you sir
yes or members miss Alvarez mr. Dane thank you but the one thing that we
didn't capture in this is you know that there are school consolidations that
also came in that capital plan I just wanted to to say you know on the record
that we had 24,000 students ten years ago we roughly have that same amount now
what we're seeing is they're in different areas and so you know because
of that that ultimately leads to us having to close three schools and
consolidate students so I think it's just imperative that as we continue to
grow we have to realize that the schools are adapting the best they can with the
same enrollment that they've had for a long time yeah that's very fair to say
we continue to work with the city and what they project for enrollment and
growth in areas around to continue to inform our plan so again another reason
for the flexibility is to to not lock in something now but be able to see over
the next couple of two three four five ten years what that looks like so you
know in our capital plan there's consideration for expansion and
otherwise mr. Nod yeah if I can to miss Alvarez's point this isn't directed at
you mr. Dane but just for general purposes and awareness for constituents
watching you know mr. Van der Verde mr. Madsen McGuffey and mr. Davis and the
entire city administration do a great job in supplying us and making sure that
we will we are well resourced to analyze that data for capital planning purposes
there I think that it's an important to acknowledge an additional layer of
context which is the current funding mechanism for public education is such
that we can only build based on enrollment so why you may see four
thousand single-family units and fourteen thousand multifamily units pop
up over the course of 24 to 48 months in the city limits of Huntsville one
there's other education opportunities of families are taking advantage of
outside of the public system and to those units don't always translate to
students in seats and k-12 classroom environments and so I just think it's
important for the general public to understand that while your
administration does a fantastic job on organizing and analyzing that data it's
not an exact science and it's not a perfect science but we're very thankful
for the job that you guys do with it such as an additional layer of context I
think is important to acknowledge for folks thank you for sharing that my
also ask what impact the court order has on facilities and facilities is one of
the green factors where are we on that and how does that fit into this capital
plan well we are working under a court approved capital plan now so any major
change and I don't know what the definition of major equals but any major
change to it would would require court approval and the court has approved this
capital plan and so we will be sticking with this capital plan as her has
approved it correct yes ma'am how close are we to getting clearance on that
we're waiting we have submitted the court did meet with our team and the
deck and so we are hoping within the next few months that we do receive that
order for facilities thank you and then can I just say we're tracking on our
capital projections I mean we're on track there's not been any
unanticipated hurdles no hurdles no but there's always there are always things
that will that will cause us to pivot so nothing major as of an hour ago we will
be at about 55 percent under contract of the entire capital plan as of the
limestone county project will be about 60 to 365 percent under contract for the
capital plan which means we have a handful more major renovations a
handful more new constructed buildings and and then again just the deferred
maintenance so no we're tracking right where we need to be funding wise as well
all right there are no other comments or questions thank you very much mr. Dane
we will now hear so we've talked about how we're growing how that growth is
being accommodated with the capital plan our next piece is the funding because
nothing happens without funding and our director of urban and economic
development Shane Davis will lead us in that discussion thank you madam
president mayor battle dr. Sutton school board members City Council good
afternoon thank you for this opportunity to brief you all in one setting I think
it's a unique opportunity for both of you guys and also for general public as
you're aware there's a proposed TIF 9 district that both Mass County
Commission this City Council body will take up in the next few weeks I don't
want to get into that but before that I want to talk about TIF districts in
general most of this body here it's been quite a while since we've introduced a
TIF district in Madison County in recent years we've introduced a couple in
limestone County one of those is closed out so I thought it'd be a good
refresher just to go through TIF district where we've been and where we're
going and the benefits those have brought to our community both to the
school board and the City Council and then get more specifically into that
TIF 9 district okay so just kind of what I just really what is a TIF district
our history of TIF districts in Huntsville and those successes and then
we'll get into TIF district 9 that's being proposed so what is a TIF district
the creation of a tax increment financing or TIF district is a tool that
allows municipalities complete public infrastructure improvements by using
increment tax revenue or future revenue streams not any existing revenue streams
within that district those existing revenue streams continue to flow through
the tax recipients as they do today the principles very simple the city makes
public improvements in a defined geographic area the district if you will
with the intent of stimulating new private investment or new economic
development within that district or that boundary as new development occurs the
taxable value or that new tax base that's being created by those new
investments go with it stay within the district to pay off projects if they're
paid for by cash or the or debt service and then as you roll through that and
you pay off those bonds or you pay off that project the TIF district is closed
in all new tax recipients or the tax receipts received they're proportional
of those new taxes that were created as a result of those public investments one
understand misunderstanding that sometimes people think is are we
increasing taxes no by the Alabama Constitution it takes a vote of the
people to increase any property tax ie the millage rate for Madison County for
all of us combined it's 58 mills the creation of TIF district keeps that
millage at 58 mills the city of Huntsville the administration or the
City Council adjusts anybody's property taxes we actually have elected official
the county tax assessor that evaluates all taxes within the county and provides
that assessment so the City Council nor the Mass County Commission passing a
TIF district does nothing to affect one's individuality of their tax base
that's done by the tax assessor lastly no it as I mentioned no existing tax
revenues dedicated for schools the county or city budgets were reduced or
diverted within a TIF district it's only the new tax base or the increment growth
within that district that is captured we'll get into that for TIF none in very
specific since 2000 the city of Huntsville as you can see on the screen
has completed several TIF districts the ones that you see kind of grayed out
tips 1 2 3 3 a 4 and 6 have been closed TIF 5 is redstone arsenal which is
active TIF 7 that was created in limestone County as a result the Mazda
Toyota economic development project is active we are considering
administration with limestone County Commission a future TIF 8 in limestone
County and then we'll get into the proposed TIF 9 district here in
Madison County so this is a list of those tips that I just showed you on the
screen and when they were established the number of years it took for them to
close out and the public improvements that were put in those TIF districts so
we'll go through those TIF one was the very first one this the city ever did it
was really small in its way as far as its boundary but the the improvements
were very large it was US Highway 72 widening from essentially just east of
research Park Boulevard to just west of Providence main and then the widening and
improvements McMurphy Drive this brought the Target Center if you've been out in
that general area it was a former junkyard and we saw massive investment
along there new tax base created but it did take a while to close it was one of
our first and we've gotten better as you can see through that experience TIF 2
helped build a new Huntsville High School and a public parking garage for
partway place mall was created in 2000 it took about five years we saw a mass
improvement along the Parkway and capital investment in and around that
medical district area TIF 3 constructed a new Providence Elementary School in
Columbia High School made improvements to Feral Road and Old Monrovia
improvements in and around research Park that district was created again in 2000
and took 18 years to complete now I do want to point out by the statute
Alabama statute TIF district maximum term is 30 years so you can see all of
these are have accelerated much early closure TIF 3a provided 12 million
dollars to Huntsville City Schools for various school improvements built the
first phase of the northern bypass the new north Huntsville Industrial Park that
gave way to Toyota engine plant and now plethora of industry up there and the
Wade Mountain Preserve expansion our first greenway in that district one and
Trailhead TIF 4 again you kind of see the theme in blue of you know
understanding what the TIF does as far as to our tax recipients and trying to
build in projects where we can to yield to that deferred tax recipient TIF 4 was
was no exception with 13 million dollars in school improvements both Lee and
Butler High Schools expansion of the art museum some minor improvements the Vaughn
Braun Center a new downtown public safety precinct which combined police
and fire for downtown let us to kind of get better service throughout the entire
city building that facility and then redrawing the response or boundaries for
public safety courthouse improvements and then Harris Hill Boulevard that gave
way to east side of highway 72 East now we're seeing growth in that area nine
years to closure I was a credit in 2006 TIF 5 is one of our active tips it was
Redstone Gateway Park in partnership with the Gerson Redstone Arsenal and
produced Redstone Gateway Park TIF 6 is also closed included Chase Farm Road
Greenbower Parkway sewer improvements and I do want to circle back to this it
proposed a new K-8 school in Limestone County when we created that tip a few
years later it was determined based on rooftops and the feasibility of Humsville
City Schools moving forward with that to delay that TIF 8 as I mentioned we are
evaluating could possibly bring that project back into that future TIF
district one of the things I do want to discuss about TIF districts although I
have a term of 30 years that they must be closed out all projects must start
in the first five years any project that hasn't started within that time period
rolls out of the its qualification so that was the case with this K-8 school so
in 2015 and there's an error there it says 20 years that project closed out
several years ago then tip 7 our latest tip and also in Limestone County Greenbower
Parkway extension of what old highway 20 improvements and sewer improvement that
is going very well very ahead of schedule due to the mass amount of
industrial projects we've seen along that Greenbower Parkway corridor the
likes of Mazda Toyota Amazon VTEC the list goes on and on that we're seeing
out there so again kind of nutshell here of just kind of taking you through
everything that has occurred in this district so 70 million dollars in new
school improvements in all tips that the city has created 240 million dollars in
new public capital and infrastructure projects from public facilities public
safety roads utilities new private investments exceeding eight and a half
billion dollars I think that's the key of why you do tips and return on that
investment a new tax base has been created at least tips generating 110
million dollars annually so how does that break down 47 million dollars of
new revenue has been created for Huntsville City Schools annually 22
million dollars for the City of Huntsville General Fund and just under 20
million dollars for the Mass County Commission General Fund those would be
just in the tip districts have been closed those revenue streams would not
include any existing tip districts that are open so that number would only
increase as we close those districts out so I want to walk you through what is in
front of and had been in the news coming for this City Council come for a Mass
County Commission it would be a new tip district 9 so tip district 9 would
create a new tax district primarily consisting of the central portion of the
city would encompass about just under 3,700 acres that is not the largest tip
district we've created North Huntsville and tip 6 & 7 were a little larger than
that all proposed activities by law and public work projects must take place
within the corporate limits of the City of Huntsville one of the reasons I want
to point that out see a small black box in the central southern portion of that
that map there that's actually low mill so that is a tax island I can tell you
though with some of the investments that we'd like to do in this district there
has been discussions of that coming in being annexed into the city now what I
want to point out there is should that come into the city be annexed and more
investment happen in there the tip district would not catch that new
revenue that would go immediately to the tax recipients so there's a benefit
there of us being able to induce that or entice that to come into the city be
immediate plus up to all of our general fund the new tip district 9 contains
properties that are currently under your laws are underdeveloped and we believe
with the investments that I will show you we can stimulate redevelopment and
new private investment within this proposed district furthermore the
development or redevelopment of areas located within this district we don't
believe can be fully realized without some of these capital improvement
projects we've had a good run downtown we really have I mean you've seen new
hotels you've seen new multifamily but we've about reached our limit of where
private investment is willing to go downtown without some new inducement
some new interest that would drive more activity so the first project would be
the largest project in the district would be expansion of the North Hall of
the Vaughn Braun Center over the years we've delayed this project we have
taken capital funds out of the city's budget so graciously approved by the
City Council to take and do small projects if you've been in the Vaughn
Braun Center at any time in the last couple of years you've seen improvements
to hallways you've seen improvements to the existing expansion of South Hall the
existing North Hall what you don't see in the back is back-of-house
improvements but we're at an impasse with the Vaughn Braun Center so we have
some very large conferences that come in that have for the three straight years
not been able to fulfill all the people who want to participate in that so may
kind of tell you how conferences work let's take something like a USA where if
you happen to stroll the halls and over several council members did they were
every nook and cranny in the BBC everywhere anywhere they could put a
booth they put a booth and sold a booth and they were short about 70 vendors that
wanted to be there now how conferences make money is based on being able to sell
a booth so three straight years this is our largest defense contract conference
here that as we know Redstone Arsenal Research Parts a lot below this economy
their inability to satisfy those has them potentially looking at should they
continue here we used to host Quad A here same thing happened at Quad A it's
now in that excuse me in Nashville is that a reason to expand North Hall not
necessarily but we've run the math of what we know that front row would do in
another phase what Hart of Huntsville Mall area in that redevelopment is not
moving forward without seeing that and some other properties in around the
downtown area that we know would make a significant investment that would help
us all from a future tax base the North Huntsville Beltline Greenway we think
that is a significant project to see redevelop along North Parkway along
Meridian Street and Church Street that area has not been kind to what I would
say past infrastructure project mainly by all but the widening of the Parkway
so what this does is create a new front door back door along the east side of
the Parkway we see a lot of underutilized properties there that we in
talking with people we introduced this last year anybody's been to Atlanta and
seen that Atlanta Beltline what that has done is probably the single most
impactful project in the city Atlanta's history I think you know it's 30 years
old but over a trillion dollars of private investment now this is not that
linked but this would be the first phase for the city of Huntsville we think it's
the most important phase it connects into downtown it connects to Holmes
Avenue that provides linkage between UAH Alabama A&M Cummings Research Park
downtown all the way into John Hunt Park with a park project that is underway
new Mill Creek Park that's our choice neighborhood redevelopment project
putting five million dollars in a public park there we know that will help
accelerate at least two phases of an eight phase project and allow that
project to know it will move forward in all phases that is also in partnership
with Huntsville Housing Authority with private investment all the new
construction that that this would take place at Mill Creek would be private so
it means it pay taxes so you know much like City of Huntsville and the school
board your tax exempt with Huntsville's housing authority but they will maintain
the dirt so all vertical improvements will pay 58 mills tax regardless okay so
that can be a significant boost and needle mover for all of us Low Avenue
and Huntsville Junior High Improvement so as you're aware of your project with
Huntsville Junior High Improvements there's there's improvements that we
need to do along low to make sure that kids that want to walk to school and
some pedestrian facilities there but the remaining portion of those funds would
be to the school board to help facilitate the construction of Huntsville
Junior High we believe the city's portion of the road and public improvements is
about a million dollars it leave about four million dollars from city schools
to finish the construction that project as talking with the Mass County
Commission they are looking at what to do with the courthouse and how do they
rebuild courts how do they rebuild their offices and where they hold their
meetings we know that that process will be lengthy and require some displacement
so with the construction or in the completion of the federal courthouse GSA
donated if you will the former federal courthouse to the city to be caretakers
of it for the city we we don't have a purpose for it so making five million
dollars in renovations to the former federal courthouse to allow the County
Commission and or the courts move in to there as part of what they do with the
future current County courthouse facility so as we do this we also try to
model what future tax revenues would look like and and this comes from a
variety of information information from private investment has that has made
investments in their downtown they still have properties and have chose for
whatever reason not to move forward with additional investments areas that we know
where these projects will be the highest and best use is not what is there now
some of its vacant land some of its distressed properties and we start to
see based on zoning and in the top amenities that this TIF would place in
there we start modeling like-minded new projects so take homes at Clinton
Avenue for instance if you got stove house and you start to see that the top
investments being made there if we can induce between stove house back to the
BBC we have you know data that shows when that building permit was pulled
mainly for multifamily mixed use or a restaurant so we start to model that in
certain spots and then we get a good capture what that new private investment
is most likely to be we do that for all TIF district we're very conservative with
it what you've seen in that chart I showed you our conservative part is to
really make sure this thing doesn't last 30 years all none of our TIFs we've been
very conservative on what that backside investment would be because we want
these things to pay off accelerate get the projects done and get it closed
that's the goal of our TIFs so let's get into numbers really quick and then
open up to questions so the gray shaded area that you see that is what we
refer to as the 2025 baseline tax revenue that came from the Mass County
tax assessor's office so total for this district should City Council and Mass
County Commission approve the baseline is just over 29 million dollars that
annual 29 million dollars continues to get cut up and sent to all tax
recipients the tip district captures is not one penny of that so what that means
this City Council and the school board to the city of Huntsville it's just
under six and a half million dollars you will continue to get that that's what
the blue line is showing and and the white bar dots that you see every year
that tax base is frozen it goes to Huntsville City Council or City General
Fund the green bar represents the Huntsville City Schools General Fund
just under 11 million dollars that continues to flow into Huntsville City
Schools just as if they're one of tip district then there's a dashed orange
line there there's a countywide education tax it's currently at 2.9
million dollars now that can fluctuate how that gets distributed because it's
based off overall enrollment of Madison County in your percentage or Huntsville
City Schools percent that overall enrollments how that's cut off I did
want to try to calculate that because it probably changes a little bit each year
but just know that base that would get divided between the three school systems
would not change that 2.9 million dollars continues to flow out to those
schools okay so let's start looking at okay what if the gray box at the bottom
is is that same 29 million dollars the burnt orange line that you see is new
tax revenue from the existing tax base what do what I mean by that so with that
represents a 3% increase by year every year for 30 years so what does that
mean so let's say I have a piece of property is worth $100 okay and the
Mass County tax assessor in 2026 says it went up in value by 3% we don't
determine that it may go up 0 it could go up 5% 7% they determine that that's
what that would indicate that additional $3 so the way we typically model that
is we just do 3% inflation and and we typically get over that long span pretty
close we've seen the tax assessor in recent year do you know 5 to 6% then
when you're being one and a half cent but I think what we've seen if we model
just 3% for inflation it gets pretty close okay then the blue that you see
that is the new tax revenue that we projected in those green circles that I
pointed of having new capital investment that start to occur you notice in year
one it's almost nothing right the far left and then we think what we typically
see is those first 36 months that three-year timepan as we start to deploy
this public improvements we see that capital investment start to come in and
then as you see it round up don't forget that that new investment also is not
immune to the adjusted tax rate that the inflation or whatever the tax assessor
you know if I placed a project in year two and paid my taxes in year three I'm
a new tax participant but if they adjusted everyone's taxes by 3% in the
district because of inflation or whatever that new tax base is also went
up so that's when you see it to the right it starts to really hook hook up
to a vertical position as you get now or years because it's playing the same
inflation it's not all just new tax coming on but those big projects as they
hit once they're in the system they get treated just like the brown or the
maroon part so I thought I'd make this a lot simpler just to what does it mean to
the school board so again I showed that your ten point nine eight million
dollars of existing revenue to get annually that does not change during the
life we have projected that this tip would pay off in 14 years so on average
if I do a ten-year average of that 3% inflation of your tax base should the
tax assessor every year take it 3% 3% and I do that on average across that
that term is about four hundred and eight million dollars per year or for
the entire 14 years at six point three million dollars so now you start to put
in the five million dollars that this district would deliver to the school
board it's almost budget-neutral not quite plus or minus a million dollars
but what happens once we pay the TIF off at upon closure year 15 that first year
you'd see an increase of seven point six eight million dollars added to the ten
point nine eight so you go from ten point nine eight let's say that we did not pass
the tip okay if you took the ten point nine eight plus the four hundred million
dollars so about eleven if we do nothing about eleven point three million dollars
before you'd be in 14 years versus the seven point six plus the ten point nine
you're just under 19 so it's a plus up net of about six and a half million
dollars a year once the tip is closed out I'll take any questions and I'll go
back to a slide I know I plowed through a lot but I wanted to get the question
that was a lot of information it was thank you Shane nobody does numbers like
Shane does council members I and board members I'm sure you have questions who
wants to start by mr. Merida we'll let the school board go first board members
and I have one miss Albert okay so there are if you include if you don't include
the proposed tip eight just based on the two tips that are open plus this proposed
third one it's about four hundred and six million dollars of that four hundred
six million dollars only five of it is allocated to Huntsville City Schools
historically the other tips were a lot smaller and and included schools is there
a reason that we're not using education money to invest into education I think
we are I think what I would argue at least for this tip or point out are just
too strong of a word what you would give up in education funds is about six point
one three million dollars for just this tip what about the other two let me let
me stay here we'll go back okay so six point one three million dollars over
fourteen years he took the net present value that is less than five right and
this project has five this tip has five million dollars to the school board for
Huntsville Junior High so to me it's almost a net zero impact right now let's
go to tip six and seven thank you go look at tip six and tip seven without
the tip there would not be about three point five billion dollars of taxes on
the tax roll because without Green bar Parkway without the utilities there would
be no players no Amazon no Mazda Toyota so all that was farmland I need to go
back and look and I can follow up with Dustin and get you this information so
it's all accurate I would gauge that your revenue prior to those tips in that
area was probably less than $20,000 a year because it was current use
agricultural there wasn't anything on it yet so we haven't reached the benefit
one of the two has and the other ones accelerating but I guess the point I'm
making is the revenue that you see tip seven producing without the tip district
that revenue would not exist right but and what I'm trying to reiterate is it
does not exist to us yet and it won't until the proposed payoff 2047 that's
the whole goal of a tip district right and I'm saying that's a generation so you
know my fifth grader will be my age by the time some of these tips are proposed
to be paid off and is that really an investment into education well it will
be the other way to look at it would be just don't do tip seven instead of those
multi-million dollars that will be coming to all school systems we could be
splitting $25,000 if I can mr. Davis not that not the short here I think a
different perspective that I'm looking at this from not to contradict or
counteract this out for this point because I think she's well rooted and
burst in her disposition that we want to make sure we're using education funds
to invest in education also agree with your disposition that we are here and
I'll add an additional layer of perspective here which is when we're
talking about tax assessed values and what's being captured in the tip we are
strictly talking about property tax is that correct yes we are not talking
about sales tax that is correct which sales tax is another revenue generator
for us which test districts afford the city and the school district a direct
benefit by an increase in sales tax revenue primarily because when we talk
about the private investment coming into the tune of billions of dollars we're
talking about the investment in property which more often than not in a district
like this is generating additional sales tax revenue so while we may not realize
a return on investment from the property tax perspective throughout the duration
of the tip we are realizing immediate gains from the schools in an increase in
sales tax revenue generation and I would I be accurate in an assessment you'd be
be correct one of the things I would point out is kudos to the school board
you're in the middle of a six hundred million dollar capital plan right I
would argue the tips that I showed you a close you would not be in a position
where you're at today without those tips creating those new private investments
getting them closed out and that revenue flowing to you I just with all the
growth that's happened in Huntsville without eight and a half billion dollars
of private investments now paying school taxes they're paying city taxes or
paying county taxes without those TIF districts it wouldn't be nowhere near
that would it be something absolutely you know a billion two billion we could
argue that but it's nowhere close to eight and a half billion dollars so
speaking of the capital plan we have anticipated a certain level of growth in
our capital plan to fund it oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
mission well I'm sorry without being recognized let's make sure miss Alvarez
has had a chance to finish to finish her thoughts did you have any other questions
all right miss no okay sorry speaking about the capital plan obviously we
anticipated a certain level of growth within our capital plan to fund that and
that included city growth without this TIF district because we were I guess
unaware of it so one thing is what sort of prompted this it seems like it was a
little bit sudden and second I guess that might be something for Dustin also
is that still without capturing any growth in this district which is a
fairly large district are we confident that we're still going to meet the goals
of our capital plan as far as growth and also if you said something about private
investors weren't cautious about this district they didn't want to continue
investing in it so why just the city so those are my probably three compound
questions all great questions so we try to follow those in order if I miss one
please repeat it okay so the first I think your capital plan working with
Dustin is secure again this ten point just call it eleven million dollars is
still going to flow to you the you know four hundred eight thousand per year if
you will net present value is probably about four point six million dollars
this this plan has five million dollars direct out allocation to you so we
essentially cover that for you so everything in blue is just new money
that would come so the district was larger as we looked we looked at areas
that we know are going to grow in North Huntsville and further south so we've
shrunk it originally it went north of Oakwood and went to Airport Road so we
pulled it all the way back up to Drake Avenue and actually went further west
really to just west of Jordan Lane so we've shrunk it to the west shrunk it to
the south and shrunk it to the north and there's not exact science to that so it
it's kind of a push or pull of how big of an area to capture to accelerate paying
this thing off as fast as possible and get you that just seven point seven
million dollars or make it as small as possible and painful for all of us to
carry out for 30 years what we've typically done is try to accelerate it
as quickly as possible to close and let everybody start getting this new revenue
and if I miss one please bring it back up I'm sorry yeah again if we're like
private investors are cautious why are we not why is the city willing to risk
it well it's through our office having conversation with private investment
take the front row for instance they've only done one phase of four I do know of
a multi-story building if you look at some of the renderings on al.com
there's a 22 story complex office building with Commission style hotel and
condos without more conferences coming here that building doesn't happen should
we announce the North Hall expansion we know that building move forward that's
a significant move the needle in this TIF district to accelerate payoff on it
also other hotel years that have seen where their ADR and where their oxy
rate is downtown the new hotels they know with more conventions the
expansion of the North Hall does not just to handle the large convention we
can't cover now but is like able to have two in one week you know split the
Bonbon Center up much like other convention centers in Southeast United
States where the CVB and the BBC or the Sports Commission they can all be
recruiting those type of events here on the same week you know a lot of times you
take a USA for instance we lose three weeks with a one-week conference that's
the most important conference we hold it's Redstone Arsenal Research Park but
they lose the week before for everybody to load in they lose the week of the
Commission going on and then it's almost a week after for everybody to load out
see so that one conference almost cost you a month worth of sales tax and
different revenue streams that we all could benefit from but it's it's really
working with us hoteliers to the own property downtown that says look there's
just not enough demand you got to go create more demand and I'll create more
investment that's really the whole intent of a TIF district give an example
for TIF 6 in Lomston County we strictly did it because Polaris come we knew what
that CapEx was we knew we needed to get utilities on a road bill or they weren't
coming because the road didn't exist it's just all farmland in the middle of
nowhere the reason they accelerated and paid off so quick is once we put those
utilities that road in three under three other industry located on there it just
burn off in a matter of couple years that's what's happened with TIF 7
Mazda Toyota since that time Mazda Toyota put 2.6 billion we've already
exceeded to 4 billion there so so again it's go prime the pump make these small
investments and then watch it accelerate that's the whole premise behind the
Alabama Constitution of Taxing and Financing great question council
members I think mr. Meredith you have a question and then mr. cling mr. Davis
could you define what you mean by payoff payoff would mean that all debt if we
issue bonds which we most likely do have been closed or paid off what usually
happens in acceleration format is again I'll do simple math okay bond payments
$10 a year at the first part of it the tip district may only produce $2 see
his capital plan will make up that other eight we don't ask any of your deferred
tax receipts hey this tip district small we give us some money pay this this $10
debt we cover it but then as the years progress it starts producing 12 15 20
that's how you accelerate paying the debt off but once it's closed it the debt
is paid off the tip must be closed that new revenue that was paying that debt
service or accelerating that payoff now gets divided amongst the tax recipients
thank you you mentioned how the tax assessor may raise the the tax or the
you know what I'm trying to say yes the evaluation it's my understanding now we
are limited to 7% increase in any given year that is that does the tax creation
of a TIF does that the limit of 7% still apply or or can they raise it 10 to 12
percent if they want and thought about that's very good question though it will
be limited by Alabama law which is that 7% but we you know the this council the
mayor Mass County Commission even you know we have no bearing on that that's
actually falls in the hands of the tax assessor but you you're correct it
doesn't change any laws that set any limit mr. Davis and this just answer your
question as we were is that that law was being put in place we talked to
lieutenant governor who was pushing that and he was able to pull out most of the
TIF districts out of out of that that legislation so I don't think that the
TIF districts will be will be hindered in those I appreciate what you're trying
to do by answering the question but I would more greatly appreciate not being
interrupted when I have the floor he was just trying to answer the question I
understand he was trying to answer my question but he interrupted me while I
had do you have any other additional I do have additional please go ahead thank
you for a TIF district you need 50% of the district to be considered blighted
is my understanding well is that correct the law actually changed this session
okay what is it what was it adjusted to that you can exceed more than 50 percent
is the way the law was written certainly there's not it didn't say you know no
more than 70 just said it they took the I guess my point is but we've ran that
math and this does comply if if you could pull up a map show me where the
blighted parts are well there's six actually six points of a TIF statute
blight is one of those but also also economic distress or properties that are
not in its highest and best use based on zoning and its adjacent tax values so
there's a whole series of I call them the six TIF statutes or warrants if you
will the one that you mentioned being blighted is just one of those six can
you show me what would be considered blight in this tech well it's according
what's your definition of blight is blight can be for instance a tax value
that is I'm gonna make up easy math again okay I like easy man yeah hundred
dollars is this property's value you know two parcels over the values 20,000
so that is a piece of distress or undervalued piece of property not in its
highest and best use and roughly if you could use your mouse where in this if
this mouse word would I would say a large portion is up in this area here
certainly around the Holmes Avenue and the low mill areas we're seeing some
reinvestment but most of those properties have not really changed in
its use in probably five six seven decades and then in and around the
downtown district area it would be the vacant properties or you know second
third fourth generation top buildings that are underserved as far as its
rent roll rates you know it's kind of hard to give you a parcel-by-parcel
description of those but we did work with GIS to run some of that okay we can
talk offline sure and then finally I just want to encourage you to talk with
the Madison County Commission I know they're pretty concerned about what this
TIF would do in terms of the effect on both Madison City and Madison County
school systems and we have those numbers I got final preliminary numbers from
Cliff man's office on Friday I've actually sent that to Jeff rich today
and they were there was some confusion of some numbers the County Commission
had run and they I will tell you they were 10x what they thought it was so I
think a lot of that has been subsided today thank you very much you're welcome
sir mr. clean mr. Davis based upon past history do you feel that the numbers
that you're projecting on the new TIF 9 is conservative excessive I mean what
do you think the ultimate outcomes gonna be I do councilman clean as I said by
statute a tip district in the last 30 years right now based on you know the
2014 capital plan that will see the TIF district in early years meaning the debt
service versus the tax revenue coming in they don't match meaning this the city
will actually write a check for those debt service payments in early years
which accelerates the payoff right it's one of all these work but right now
we're modeling in a conservative manner between year 14 and year 15 this close
it out so there would be a chance and we're not trying to you know sugarcoat
it there could be a chance that based on your projections if it's like other tips
that we've had the school system may be getting more perhaps quicker than the
30-year payout that this thing is built into is that an exam is that reasonable
that's right the number that let me go back to here so again this number is
based on year 14 to 7.6 million but let's say let's just pick a number let's
say it was year 11 that number is 6.9 million okay but then as inflation
happens those years you get to this number so the number would be a little
less because the TIF has not as mature but it would start early so you're
correct that's a long way of saying yes okay thank you any other council members
have miss Watkins good evening thank you miss Davis for their presentation can
you tell us how does the city currently support Houseful City schools and how do
we go above statement date of funding as far as the finances piece of mass penny
Smith who can go through six and a half meals and the 22 and a half meals you
like to speak on that and the capital plans good afternoon penny Smith
director of finance so a couple of ways we've been we contribute to the
Huntsville City schools and to their bottom line first is already mentioned
the sales and use tax that comes through the city 14 14 percent of 3.5 percent
goes through goes to the city school system directly each month and and that
is remitted to our schools there is a trip at the end of the year so that so
that tax base goes goes to there and goes forward for that the also the
capital plan so there's six and a half meals that is contributed to our general
fund six and a half meals goes directly to the school system for the
furtherance of education and and that is utilized but it really in two ways it's
it's made it is the vast majority is of it is utilized for capital and to
payment of debt that is issued by the school system I'm sorry by the city for
for all the school system things but capital plans but then also sometimes
there are payments like land or the purchase of something like that that is
a direct withdrawal from that from that corpus that goes back to to the school
system for for those capital purchases in addition to that there are numerous
other ways that both are from from capital from the capital projects that
are that are put in the ground both of our capital plans benefit the school
systems in various ways due to from sewer systems to things that we help with
on various capital plant various projects and things like that across the
city roads that that are repaired or put pushed through for the school system
that are requested by that specifically and then also our City Council has
contributed to the school system in various ways through their own
discretionary plans that they have in place I don't know if I'm mentioning in
this I'm missing one thing I'm missing the appropriation that's that goes
through every year for books as well this Watkins did that answer your
question it did but I need mr. Davis come back up thank you miss Smith so I
think it was probably was it two months ago when the Eli Lilly announcement
came through late November early December yeah time flies time flies
well anyway I received a call from Mayor battles secretary to ask me to come meet
with him in his office and you were there and I want to thank both of you
because when I got there you said you're going to be happy it sounds like well
what this is about that's what I was thinking in my head and one of the
things you shared in the mayor's well which I think both of you for is you
know with all the development that's coming out of district 5 even though
it's not in my district it's still it is a compliment to hospital City schools
that land was donated and money will be allocated to build a school out there
with all the development coming so I want to thank you for that as well as I
wanted to be noted in February hospital City of Huntsville closed out to 246 and
we presented a 5.5 million dollar check to dr. Sudden here in council chambers
so I will say this when I first got here I was talking a lot about funding for
Huntsville City Schools but I do know that the City Council and the mayor is
committed to doing what's best for us with city schools and helping them with
these facilities and the growth that we have so I thank you for that but my next
comment is going to be I know that we have planning Commission and I know that
I think mr. Bernard is to representative for Huntsville City Schools but are we
communicating clearly about the growth and the expansion and how is it going
back to house for city schools and I guess that's a question for mr. Bernard
because when I was on the council I wasn't getting this information I mean on
school board and I think it's extremely important that we're communicating this
information and that we have this dialogue because this is especially
important especially with the growth and expansion in how see schools is prepared
it's a great question let me unpack some of that I'll be the first to omit five
years ago probably not so much we were disseminating the right information and
doing it timely I'd say over the last five years we've done a really good job
and a lot of that is information we didn't have it was it was not as
advanced not as automated as it's we bought a lot of programs and inspection
department a lot of shuttle programs and engineering planning so that data is now
at our fingertips so we're able to compile it with mr. Vandiver and Thomas
Nunes and city engineer and we're able to get that and get it in a way not only
for you to understand as a school board but for us to understand and developing
capital plans so it's just the really the advancement of the tools our staff
has we've always had that data but if you would have asked for it you know
probably five seven years ago it took someone going through filing cabinets of
paper and permits and try to you know key all that in Excel and hopefully give
you some snapshots so we've gotten much better at that we'll continue to evolve
and get better we can pretty much give it to you on a month to month basis now
we get a roll up every month but you know you do bring up a good point in
limestone county and our partnerships you know the the central office and new
tech school you know that came out of the capital plan as miss penny said of
just under five million dollars we've worked with Dustin and the team where's
the best location for a new school in limestone county we don't want you to
build two campuses one on the north side of the interstate one on the south side
and be coming back to you you know with 2,000 more lots ten years from now and
say hey man that school would have been three miles the other way but it's just
not you got to have that so we worked with that found out where it should be
that said okay you can have one school district here to handle the next 30
years out here you know may need a wing addition but it's not build this campus
and go up here ten years from now build another campus and then we've worked
with landowners such that to build get 126 acres for the school board at no
cost now we're making capital investments out there bringing utilities and
improving some roads that yes the landowner will benefit down the road but
that benefit we transferred to the school board and tiff ain't we're
starting to model that but there's a very good likelihood that that tip will
include a k8 school that you're already budgeting your 600 million dollars if
that comes to fruition whatever you're going to spend on that cage you go spend
somewhere else in the school district okay so so we're working we're working
really hard I feel like we got a good partnership tips are hard I mean that
there's you know different ways to look at it I think historically I showed
we've been able to build educational facilities build public infrastructure
get them closed and then see everybody benefit all three school systems Madison
County limestone County Commission I remember I called chairman Daly limestone
County Commission when we closed tip six and and I don't remember his number but
I called him and said hey we're closing tip six and here's the amount to
limestone County schools here's meant to the County Commission he said man we
could really use that this year I said well Commissioner it's that plus every
year following and he's like this is like a blessing and then the
superintendent of limestone County schools called because chairman Daly give
him a cell number he's like okay walk me through this again I said we closed them
out here's your check it's a partial tax year because we closed it out not you
know somewhere in the middle call penny and got the actual number for the next
year and call that back that's collaborative partnership it mean it's
right or wrong I think we could all could debate that but I think long term
if we really look down the road we've shown past success and I really think
we'll show future success in continuous trend thank you well I really I'm not
done I'm really excited about this meeting today because it shows that
Huntsville City Schools in the city of Huntsville is collaborating and
communicating for the benefit of our city and well as our schools and
students I have another question for you Shane yes ma'am are we communicating
with Huntsville City Schools when it comes to the skill sets that's needed
for our upcoming graduates being that we have a state of the art Career Tech
Center I know you know businesses industry drive our workforce are we
communicating those needs to Huntsville City Schools I think so you know our
workforce development team but the chamber works very closely to all our
school system or two-year colleges or four-year colleges I've got to tour that
new facility kudos to this board I can't wait to see the programs that keep
coming out of it but before that facility was built we were behind no
disrespect to anybody up here but you know what AIDT was having to do what
Calhoun was having to do we send a lot of people limestone Career Tech Center
was one of the best in the state they can't say that anymore
kudos to this board the facility that you have put on the ground is absolutely
phenomenal and the programs will only get better we see it every day I mean
last year very very quietly in this community we created about 5,000 jobs
you know what in the miles of Toyota that we announced them all at once but
of those almost 73% you can get with high school diploma GED with a little
bit tech training and go make 67,000 dollars a year so that facility will bring
benefits this community for generations to come so kudos to you guys for having
that vision we're glad that we were a part of it don't forget Michelle
Watkins was on that board that got their Career Tech Center approved I fussed about it
every day Beth can say she sat next to me I do have another comment though I
know that there has been a lot of talk on Facebook about the BBC and this tip
but this is the reality I've attended several conferences being on the council
you get invited to conferences I went to the SMDC which one is one of the largest
conferences we have at the Civic Center and last year they were really excited
because Golden Dome was discussed in there are so many government agencies
and contractors there and when I went last year they took me through and was
touring we are so out of space that people were in hallways with their
display booths hallways and little side entrances they fit them in everywhere
they could because they had actually ran out of space and I know when you're
trying to attract large conferences to the city you got to have hotel space
as well as you have to have space at your facility and I know that one
organization did not come because we didn't have enough breakout rooms and
they passed elsewhere over for their reason so I totally understand the BBC
expansion our city has grown and if we want to attract seminars and workshops
and events to this city that are of a magnitude that we want to show that
Huntsville can handle it we have to have that space available at the BBC but at
no time is the schools being slighted not at all education is still at the
forefront of the thoughts of this city and I do have to say that we are
dedicated to working with Huntsville City Schools to ensure that that happens
so thank you Shane I don't think anyone in this room other than council members
and the mayor and people that work at the city really understand the job that
Shane does Shane works seven days a week and not only that anytime you call him
y'all might call him at two or three o'clock in the afternoon eight or nine
o'clock at night Shane is calling me back because he has been too busy to
return a phone call so thank you Shane you're too kind I'm just one of many
mayor battle I know you have some thoughts on all of this please share
those with us thank you and thank you to the council for having this and thank
you for the school board for joining us with this I think this is one of the
most important conversations we can have we are no better than our education
system we cannot grow we cannot prosper unless we have a good education system
and we've all got to work with that work together to make sure that we have that
education system back when we did TIF was it six with Toyota Mazda seven
when we did TIF seven former superintendent came to me and said I'm
going to oppose that because I don't like taking away the revenues that I'm
going to have in the future off that land and and I had to explain to him and
I said you know you've got to realize I mean this is something this is a three
billion dollar investment that's going to be happening with that land that three
billion dollar investment once it's once the debts paid off for what the TIF the
TIF process was it brings in 17 million dollars a year that 2400 acres that
sitting out there is taxed at rural farm rates $750 an acre and then it's then
it's taxed at 10% of their assessed value so each acre of that land out
there that 2400 acres is taxed at $75 an acre you put that $75 an acre together
and you got a total assessment of $180,000 which is what that land would be
assessed for today if if we had not done Mazda Toyota 180,000 versus for three
billion dollars that 180,000 would would give us what do you think Shane about
about eight eight eight thousand nine thousand dollars a year eighteen nineteen thousand dollars a year
right now that that property is kicking off about 17 million dollars a year that
is going back into our school systems and back into our community you know
we've got to remember and take the long look and that's what Huntsville's always
been good at taking that long look looking ahead 15 20 25 years and seeing
what it's going to do to us and how it's going to make us a better community you
know we we had our conversation I think we were able to needless say we were
able to do the tip and as we did the tip we watched it very closely and today I
think that it has been a great partnership with the school board with
the school administration with everybody and I as a citizen of Huntsville but
also as mayor I also want to thank each of you for the job that y'all done to
make sure that we have a great education system and that we're able to pay for
that great education system no other system across the state is able to put
six hundred million dollars into a capital plan right now to have better
schools better and better facilities for their for their young students and as we
do that we'll see the we'll see the long the long game of that we'll see in 10 15
20 25 years we'll see we'll see each year we'll see a gain in our community
and the prosperity of our community keep on coming in day after day after day you
know because of the decisions that y'all have made and the work that y'all done
over the past thank each of you for your efforts council thank you for your
efforts in this this is a long play I mean it's a play for a long term but the
long term is that it benefits our community and benefits our children long
term thank you thank you mayor battle mr. not thank you dr. Roberts I just
councilman Watkins wanted to answer one brief question you had directed is and
I'm confident my board colleagues will attest to this but they get no less
than three emails from me every month being the Planning Commission agenda
zoning subcommittee agenda and then the subdivision subcommittee agenda so while
the communications are indirect but they are forwarded each and every month so
it's not a full breakdown but they at least get the agenda items for each
subcommittee as well as the Planning Commission and just so I can give you
all your flowers while we're up here in person there was one omission of how the
city of Huntsville does support Huntsville City Schools in the recent
passage of the SSUT member or ordinance so there is a share of SSUT revenue above
and beyond that 20 million 750 annual allocation so thank you all for that as
well miss miss miss miss miss Smith did mention it she said the sales and use
tax oh okay she did yeah and I was actually referring to my time on the
council because during my I mean on the board during my time on the board a lot
of times things were not being communicated like they should have and I
just feel that the city is growing too fast for communication elapsed so it's
great that the city of Huntsville and Huntsville City Schools is now communicating on
that and I would add to that mr. Matthews has asked for that yearly report as we
have had tonight not just the regular development review but that very
granular view down to permits and certificates of occupancy I would simply
add to what's been said tonight I when I was on the school board it was right
after tiff 2 had been created so I got to see that grow but then I was there
for tiff 3 tiff 3a to 4 and I had the same concerns that have been expressed
here tonight but it was recognizing that you can take a short-term view or you
can take a long-term view and that long-term view and I didn't realize it
until you shared the information tonight is 47 million dollars to Huntsville City
Schools annually is that correct as a result of that that comes in as a result
of growth in those tax districts it was 22 million to the city 19 to the county
and 47 million twice as much as what goes into the city operating budget as
a result of the payoff from those tips so we really are looking at this as a
mayor said the long game the return on investment is what we're making for our
children's future and that future focus is really what this is all about this
what meeting is about making those investments mr. Matthews any comments
from you you have been very quiet
think what for a reason just wanted to listen to hear what we had to say on all
of this information here one of the things I will say is is that as the
federal and state move money around for education having a strong local economy
for our citizens and our students is important and playing the long game to
make sure that we're doing the right thing of now getting schools built but
also in the future bringing revenue in for those schools and for the city is
important I think for Huntsville to have that local strong economy that is our
future because at the state and federal level we don't have control over that
we're not sure where those things are going to land but here in the city we
have an opportunity to work with our City Council to make sure that we're
doing the right things for our students and our citizens here in Huntsville so
I'm very excited for us to have had this meeting and been able to work together
to to get this going for our school system in our city thank you mr.
Matthews and I believe this Alvarez wants to make one last um so I had two
clarifying questions after listening tip 7 is not paid off correct the Toyota it
is not so we are getting close we are not getting 17 million dollars a year
as stated I don't think mayor Bell said you're getting 17 he said it's
producing that which right not going to the schools yet and the 17 million would
be divided between limestone County Commission CDF Huntsville and the two
schools districts out there and we'll get that to Dustin in the morning so
you'll have that information great I just wanted to clarify that we have not
received 17 million annually from that investment yet the other is if you'll go
back to your chart where you're determining our investment is only the
400 ish million or 400,000 a year so earlier you said okay so the seven point
six eight windfall in 2014 you then went to your charts that you're looking at
and said that if it paid off in 11 years instead of 14 years that it would be six
ish million so how can we not lose six million if we could have gained it lose
six million so if the windfall after 11 years was six million with the new
investments so you're saying as soon as it's paid off it's a huge spike in
that's right value instantly that's right okay no different than when tip 6
paid off as one of the council members said you got a check for five and a half
million dollars instantly and you'll get it the next year the next year next year
right and I understand that but this would be similar to that so but that's
not a 3% attrition rate so I'm saying when does it switch from 3% to these
higher rates but if you would have paid it off it'd be 6 million let's see we
were going so I just don't know how we didn't lose 6 million by you not paying
it off and it would have been 6 million between years 11 and 14 with an
attrition rate so I just don't understand the math yeah of so let me
walk through that a little bit okay so the gray center the 400 and just call it
four hundred nine thousand dollars there that is 3% increase on the ten point
eight over 14 years okay so you're probably guaranteed that if it tips not
happening right okay because that existing tax base the tax assessor is
going to adjust that value and reassess taxes and everybody's gonna pay the taxes
so based on that 3% per year that been historically the average if you take
that over 14 years at six point one three million dollars okay now let's get
now let's now let's go to the blue there so what is the percent you're thinking
this isn't it's almost doubling so let's go to the blue so that is investment
that has not occurred in this city it's not an adjustment somebody's property
value it has not been built it would get built and come on the tax rolls for the
very first time so let's say something happens in 2026 2027 it pays its
property tax year one of the actual property tax would pay property tax one
year in the rear so ain't something got built from there forward for the next
14 years whatever that initial value of new property tax it was generating the
TIF district is also getting that 3% escalation so you go take 20 of those
projects plus its escalation it's definitely got a very vertical growth
period versus a 3% growth period on existing property so that's why there's
such a drastic difference there and so there's there's enough plain land in
that TIF district to almost double in value we believe so 30 years yeah and if
you look at the ones that have paid off in six years in eight years with the
30 years they've paid off 300% and we're only doing we're only doing a 2x here
undeveloped land and that's why not necessarily okay if you look at North
Huntsville district with North Huntsville Industrial Park a large percentage of
that district was existing to the south right so and so I think another point is
while I do understand your math as those developers come on and as it
develops within those 14 years we're not seeing those gains and I understand
that if we wouldn't have seen them regardless but I think it is a point to
say we are probably losing more than 400k a year because we're not also
reaping anything new that does develop because it also has to go towards the
debt and so I just want to be very clear that while I do understand the windfall
and the long-term investment we also aren't getting the short-term gains and
as Ms. Watkins said about the BBC being not enough room we are feeling that at
Providence where our kids are in classrooms that are formerly closets we
also do feel the growth without the windfall coming on time with it and I
think that's just my point of view is while I do understand this and I think
it's beneficial in the long run we would also like some more short-term
assistance with the city to help us with the growth okay that's fair one of the
things I will point out to your analogy I don't disagree with tip district 9 is
going to be different than that analogy but called it is in a central business
district where the other tips have been suburban areas are outlined to where you
could get a 600 lot subdivision with five six hundred thousand dollar houses
and have four thousand of those houses or you know 500 acre farmland to get a
two billion dollar investment on it so so those would you know that I would
argue and agree with you that the incremental increase if it was in
Hampton Cove or Providence or somewhere yeah there's probably gonna be four or
five subdivisions we don't do anything that we get developed and that's brand
new tax it's a little different and we model that we do model that in those
types scenarios like tiff eight that were proposed limestone county we can
show you some of that data and say okay look this would have probably occurred so
we got to take that out of this bump up in the central business district because
you don't have that type of acreage to make that natural growth of residential
it's a little different but but I do agree with you in that sediment if this
was not in a downtown mr. not I believe you yeah just to talk about that
vertical curve on the latter half of this so I mean 90% of this is within
district four it's also have in my neighborhood where I live and eat sleep
and plays in the heart of this because I'm bad about getting out of my bubble
to Shane's point there's not a lot of a lot of there is undeveloped land you
know you look up and down the Lehman Ferry corridor which is in its early
early stages of redevelopment and then you look at stuff like Stadium Commons
which is a new ground-up build-to-suit development but you know if you were to
look at the tax assessed value of a project like Stadium Commons two years
ago before they went vertical versus today you're talking about quadrupling
8x potentially of that's what that assessed value is and that's what you're
going to see a lot of particularly along Parkway corridor where you've got
observation not a criticism of any property owners but you have a lot of
dilapidated retail and office spaces that right now you could see values
anywhere from half a million up to one and a half million for a half acre and
those are going to be teardown opportunities for private developers
you're going to come in and build of five ten fifteen million dollar
multi-story office and retail and so that vertical curve he's talking about
is it's going to take a couple years but it's it's going to be significant in the
latter half of that. If I can add he Mr. Rehner just brought up something when
someone asked about the the boundary you bring a really good point with Stadium
Commons in its first phase with three more phases to go in around John Hunt
Park our original boundary captured that and we took it out so as that continues
to be on the fringe of this district and continue to see accelerated because of
conference space in the hotels that is new revenue will all this council this
this school board will see immediate because we we've carved that out of this
district so that was where we were trying to be intentional not to say okay
well this would help further accelerate it you know we wanted to give some of
that growth to be coming on the tax rolls immediately. Mr. McAfee. I'll just
add so you know while that four hundred and eight thousand dollars that we're
seeing there when I seen that revenue come in to the school district when you
look at it it's really a wash it's actually really a wash but the donated
land and district five is out there plus the actual funding that we're going to
be able to get from the schools from the city to help fund that that completely
dwarfs this four hundred eight thousand dollars very easily so while it looks
like we're not doing anything there but the city has made that effort to make
sure that we're good on that area and take that take care of that that also
gives the superintendent I see if I'll look at the funding that we were going
to use for that school where we can place that in other areas for our
academic needs throughout our school that's right I'll defund that so I think
that you know number wise yes I can understand it makes sense but when we
look at what was done with the mayor and the City Council to donate get that lane
donated and that funding for district fire for that school that really is
going to help the situation with Providence and Williams and so forth as
we go along so I think we're I feel like we're in a good spot with that but I miss
however I do understand your concern mr. clean I think we're getting close to
wrapping things up I just want to say I think this was a very positive meeting
you've got 11 elected officials and one school superintendent all coming together
to talk about literally hundreds of millions of dollars some pretty
important issues and I think we've traveled around other cities and what we
have here you don't see too often and I think it's glad to work at the school
board my fellow council members the staff the mayor the superintendent and I
think this is something at Hudson will can be proud of and hope we can continue
to do this type of meeting maybe once a year thank you mr. cling I couldn't agree
with you more I appreciate the partnership that we have and I've mr.
Matthews and I have talked about it over the last few months as we've tried to
put this meeting together that this is a meeting that I think demonstrates I know
that the superintendent the mayor that are the finance directors meet together
regularly but I think we each all have our own partners that we that we've been
working closely with and this is great demonstration of that so mr. Matthews
thank you for working with me to put it together dr. Sutton mayor battle thank
you for what you do to to help ensure that partnership continues as well and
to the board members and council members thank you for all you each contribute as
well hope we can do this again many thanks to everybody who made this happen
the council staff the school system staff we appreciate your efforts and
unless there are any other comments we are adjourned thank you all for joining
us